so welcome everybody to the last Talk of
the day so our last week today is Young
Leo and he's going to talk about
specifying sums of norms so take it away
young thank you door for the
introduction and I will be telling you
about specifying sums of norms
so to start let me just introduce the
problem
um in the sparsification problem that
we're going to be studying in this talk
we're going to have functions F1
to FM which are functions from RN to R
let's say non-negative
and let's Define f of x to be sum over i
and m
M
red larger okay okay uh sure
um
yeah so I functions F1 and let's let
the function f of x be the sum over i
and m of f i of X okay
so this is the sum of these other
functions that take RN inputs and map to
non-negative reels and the general goal
of sparsification is to
essentially find a subset of these
functions re-weight them and show that
we haven't changed the value of the sum
by more than a one plus Epsilon Factor
more precisely we're going to call a set
of Weights
um let me just make this definition s
Epsilon sparsifier
I'm going to call a set of Weights W1 to
WM these are once again non-negative
weights we call these a s comma Epsilon
sparse fire if the following holds
the first is that the number of
non-zeros among the weights W is the
most s
and the second property is that if we
Define f tilde of x to be sum over i and
m
of w i f i of x
then
f of x minus F tilde of X and most
Epsilon times f of x for all X in RX
so this is the goal is to construct
weights W which admit which uh which are
a s comma Epsilon sparsifier and just to
get some idea for the parameters that
we're choosing in this talk kind of
here's like a dream or like a goal
is to show that maybe for some class of
functions f
uh will study certain classes in the
software some class of functions F that
we can
what's up
okay just in general okay yeah yeah okay
I'll try
it
huh in particular during the talk yes
yes
I understand
okay
so a goal would be to achieve s and most
oh something like oh tilde Epsilon to
the minus two times n that would be a
good goal to achieve in general
so you can't get this for all class of
functions but I'll try to give some
examples of functions where you can't
achieve this
in general sparsification has been very
important in designing fast algorithms
in graph Theory and numerical linear
algebra over the last two or three
decades so understanding functions where
you can sparsify can lead to maybe
further advances there let me just give
some examples
let me just go let me just give some
examples of functions where it's known
that we can sparsify
um let me start with some graph examples
in the cut sparsifier
this is generally defined
um as follows
basically here we should think as of M
as being the number of edges in the
graph and N being the number of vertices
so let if uh we're going to Define f i
of X for X in R V where V is the vertex
at f i of X is going to be absolute
value X U minus x v where you should
think that I corresponds
to the edge
u v
okay and I guess you can also put a
weight here like a weight R sub I
okay
now
another common definition is the
spectral sparsifier well here the
function is not the absolute value
anymore it's instead RI times the
difference squared
and for both these settings it's a known
how to achieve this dream goal
now I'm gonna and now uh Beyond graphs
I'm gonna call it like Matrix settings
or continuous settings
um good it's good so the question I
guess is for cut sparsifiers you want it
for all X and RN or just all zero one uh
for spectral it's normally defined that
way for cuts it's normally defined as X
being in zero one but it's actually
equivalent to this definition uh the
reason is that you can kind of like
write every every Vector X again write
it as the sum without cancellation of
the zero ones we weighted so it's
actually equivalent
okay
so the Matrix version
um basically analog of cuts is what I'm
going to call L1 sparsification and here
f of x is going to be
the absolute value of a i dot X for some
Vector a i in RN
the analog here is that AI would just be
one sub U minus like one sub B it's like
the indicator of vertex U minus the
indicator of vertex V okay so it's more
General
L2 as you might expect it's
a i dot X
squared
okay and a little more recently
um there's been people have studied
generalizations of these Notions for
example uh what it's been called
hypergraph
like the hypergraph setting so for
hypergraph cuts
one way you can think of it as now for
each eye we have a subset s i of V
and
now f i of X is going to be the max over
u v in s i
of X U minus x v
and similarly in the spectral setting
uh you once again have s i is a subset
of v and f i of X is the max over UV in
s i of this time x u minus XV
um
it's just an analogy I think it's if you
try to like for example in graph setting
spectral sparse times generalized cut
sparsifiers so if you try to find a
generalization of hyper grab cuts to
hypergraphs actually kind of get the
same thing so that's where the
definition comes
so over the last 20 years there's been a
lot of work well I guess even more than
20 years there's a there's been a lot of
work on understanding in fact what is
the smallest size of a spars of fire
that you can achieve
just uh to mention a couple for the cuts
parts of fire uh
Ben sir Karger uh show that you can get
n log n times Epsilon to the minus two
um in this L1 case which is actually
more General than the cuts bar supplier
but you'll be a little yeah so tala
Grande showed that you can also get n
log n
for the L2 case there's a lot of work
but the most uh the best bound is due to
BSS betsvin Spielman srivastava which
showed that you can get n over Epsilon
Suite without a logarithmic Factor so if
you actually don't need this otilda for
L2
okay
um also for this cut and spectral case
there's been a lot of work over the last
decade I'm just going to mention a
couple for this spectral case there's
work of Soma Yoshida
um
small Svenson travisan and then more
recently Capital Gomer Tardis Yoshida
and then uh the authors of the paper I'm
presenting today I guess
umati Lou sidford and Lee
and the best bound known here is
something like o of
that's not known here something like n
log n log R times Epsilon to the minus 2
where R is the max overall I of the size
of s it's the maximum size of any
offset okay
so this is just in general like some
a lot of things have been studied about
sparsification and to motivate the
question I'm going to be talking about
today I want everyone to make the
following observation for every function
that I've written down on this board
it's actually the power of some Norm on
our end
like this is like the this is a Norm the
norm these are actually also Norms
um because they're the max of the
absolute value of some linear function
uh so these so what you can think of
this hyper graph setting is actually
that it's a norm with the number of
faces being like polynomial in this
parameter are
um so that's another way of thinking of
the hypergraph setting and in fact all
the proofs I work for at least the
spectral setting exactly are perfectly
generalized to Norms with art faces
so um I guess in a pursuit to understand
these settings better and to generalize
the result we're going to study the
following question what if we just let f
i be a general Norm on RN and what can
we say about that setting okay
so I'm going to change notation a bit
just to clarify so here um
I'm going to let f i of x equal n i of x
where ni is a semi-norm on RN
what is a semi-normal
just to be completely clear and
satisfies two properties
if I scale by Lambda then I scale the
value by Lambda
and also it is convex
or it satisfies the triangle water
quality I guess the same as complexity
because of the scaling problem s uh
let me add a p here that's better yeah
we had a p here yeah in the end I'm
going to take P equals one for most of
it so this for all X Y in
okay good
um and now I'm going to try to State the
main theorem
to say the main theorem I want you to
find two properties of norms the first
I'm going to call the smoothness of a
norm
you see that a norm is smooth for the
power P if it satisfies the following
inequality
N I X Plus y to the P plus ni x minus y
to the p over 2 is in most the sum of
the powers
and the next we're gonna the next is
less important I'm going to just
uh
the next problem is the next property is
equivalent it's less important uh we say
that a norm n tilde is equivalent to the
norm n if it satisfies the following and
until the x is at least n x and most K
times n x for all X in R
um sorry one thing for smoothness let me
add a parameter here s to the P which is
how smooth the norm is I'm going to add
a constant here
now given this the main theorem which
I'm going to talk about for the
remainder is the following if
we have n x is the sum over i and m of n
i of x
and N this Norm
uh let me add piece Powers again p p and
N is
as smooth with this parameter s here
I want to say it's K equivalent to an S
smooth Norm
is K equivalent
to
an S smooth
Norm
then n admits
and S comma Epsilon sparsifier
or
s and most o tilde
n times Epsilon to the minus 2 times K
to the 2p times s to the p and let me
add one more condition that uh p is
between one and two
so that's the main theorem um I guess I
wanted to pause just for a second to try
to make sure everyone understands the
context and Theorem statement before I
continue
um as
wise good um I wanted this to be a
capital S and this to be a lowercase s
but I suppose that's quite unclear in
writing
um
uh for this most part this s is going to
go away for the rest of the talk like S
and K will actually go away for the rest
of the talk so you don't have to worry
too much about them I'm just going to
set them to be one for the rest of the
talk basically
maybe it makes sense to say that every
Norm is is uh one smooth so like there's
if you think about people's one then
yeah yeah yeah exactly the same as um
yeah for the rest of the talk I was
going to restrict the P equals one where
in that case notice if P equals one then
every Norm is one smooth with respect to
P equals one and that's the case I was
going to focus on for the rest of the
talk so
uh and also K would be one because I'm
I'm one equivalent to myself which is a
a one smooth for people's one so that's
the case I was going to consider for the
rest of the talk
beyond that were there any more
questions about the theorem statement
there were no questions about the
theorem statement uh then I'm going to
describe one nice application before
continuing
in the application once again I'm going
to consider the P equals one case so
notice when P equals one every Norm n
is one equivalent
to a one smooth Norm
in particular n is one Smooth by the
triangle inequality here
okay so that means any sum of norms can
be sparsified down to size about n times
Epsilon to the minus two up to poly
logarithmic factors
um one application
is in the area of like submodular
sparsification so imagine that I have
imagine that each function f i of x
is symmetric and some modular
I'm going to Define everything yeah so
assume every F5 of X is symmetric so
modular this means the following
um so I guess here uh for this part I'm
going to briefly go back to the Boolean
Cube for if only a bit um so here I'm
going to let f i b functions from 0 1 to
the N to r at least zero and we say that
symmetric is a modular if the following
properties are true f i of the empty set
I'm going to think of these as subsets
is zero
symmetric means that f i of s equals f i
of the complement set
and the third is the some modularity
property which is F5 of S Plus f i of T
is at least f i s intersect t plus f i s
Union t for all St subsets of n
so this is this is some modularity and
this is symmetry and the zero is just
for a nice normalizing condition
then I claim that for any sum of these
functions it can be sparsified down to
this size because you can check that
there exists a continuous extension of
the FIS known as the lovaz extension and
for a symmetric some modular function
the low volume extensions is actually a
semi-normon RN to see this uh
you can actually notice that the lovaz
extension of symmetrics and modular
function
of X can be defined as follows integral
over r
of I such that x i and most T DT this is
a definition of the lovaz extension of a
symmetrics modular function and you can
check that it satisfies the properties
of a norm
yes uh should clearly be f
f i of
that's much better um no this is really
bad let me just let me just call it f
not fi that's better
okay
um and the reason that satisfies the
norm properties is it's a convex by the
standard Claim about Lobos extension
that lobotics inches or convex
um if I scale X then this exactly scales
just by like you know changing what T is
in the integral and uh if I negate X
then the value stays the same because of
the Symmetry property so the Lovato
extension is a semi-norm and thus for
any sum of symmetrics and modular
functions I can sparsify it notice that
this immediately generally generalizes
like a hypergraph cuts and things like
that because those are kind of the
standard symmetrics modular functions
okay
cool
um
okay so now for the remainder of the
talk I'm going to try to basically prove
this theorem just in the case where P
equals one
and that's the ease that's like the
simplest case but has basically all of
the main ideas
foreign
ERS are constructed is via a random
sampling procedure and we can think of
it as the following very simple
algorithm
we'll call this sparsification by
sampling
it's worth noting that the tide results
that don't lose any logarithmic factors
don't work this way but I don't think
it's really known how to do those in any
settings other than L2 so spark Solution
by sampling is the following algorithm
why don't you uh Define some
probabilities P1 to PM one for each
function and these are going to be in
uh I guess 0 1 probably because
probabilities
and now
we're going to set w i to be
uh p i inverse with probability p i and
0 otherwise
and then basically the goal now is to
Define these probabilities P1 through pm
and then show that with high probability
over wi being chosen this way that the
result is actually a sparsifier
so how can we show that let's first
understand the expectation of this
sampling process and then we're going to
start studying the variance when we get
into the proof
the expectation is not too hard
um
basically this process is exactly
defined so that the expectation is that
that's unbiased for every x uh in
particular
oh look at this right here n of X is the
sum over I of n i of X right
so the expectation of w i exactly equals
one
so if we Define n tilde of x to be sum
over I of w i times n i of x
then the expectation of what we want to
be the sparsifier and tilde x equals n
of x
so it's correct in expectation
now we want to understand the variance
because the sampling is independent
across the coordinates we can
calculate the variance as follows or at
least upper bounded as follows the
variance of n tilde of X is the most sum
over I
of n i x squared times the variance
of w i
right
now what is the variance of wi wi is pi
inverse probability Pi is zero otherwise
so you can check that this is almost sum
over I
Nix squared
divided by pi
and um I guess let me for now
temporarily add this indicator that Pi
is not one
if Pi is one the variance is clearly
zero so I can always just add that there
but really this is going to be the main
term the ni x squared over pi
now let me Define one more
term which is kind of similar to the
variance but it's like the variance
between two points X and Y not just X
itself
um I'm going to call this D so I'm going
to Define d of X Y
to be the variance
of
n tilde x minus n tilde y to the
one-half power which you can check is in
most
square root over sum of I
n i x minus n i y
squared divided by pi
uh okay
cool and I'm calling this a distance
because uh this is we're going to
eventually treat d as a metric when we
go forth
okay
so here I'm going to cheat a little bit
and write something which is not
actually true but it's uh let's assume
it's true for the rest of the talk
there's various ways to make it formal
basically what I'm going to try to say
is the probability that
n of X until the x minus n tilde y
deviates from his expectation is
basically it's going to be uh the
probability has gaussian tails with uh
this variance basically so written
formally
um
this claim is not actually true there's
various ways to basically make it true
uh the probability that and of n tilde x
minus n tilde y
minus n x minus n of Y
is greater than Kappa times this
variance term
is the most X of minus Kappa squared
um okay so let me just try to describe
what this is saying one more time
recall that uh this is the probability
over the weights W1 to WM
uh so to describe what this is saying
recall that these terms are unbiased in
expectations so the expectation of this
is zero so now I'm saying that the
probability that this term deviates from
its expectation by more than Kappa times
the square root of its variance claiming
that it's sub gaussian okay uh this is
basically true because you're like
independently sampling it's not actually
true but there's various ways to make it
true let's just assume that this is true
now given this
um
the next step is to apply something
called Dudley's inequality to get the
following
uh main here's the following main claim
the expected value over W1 to WM
of the max over all X
with n of X and most one
of n of x minus n tilde of x
is at most
integral over zero to Infinity
square root log
of the covering number
uh okay I'm going to write something and
then I'm going to uh Define everything
um so here
BN is the ball
X such that n of X is and most it's the
unit ball of the norm n
so and the covering number
of a set
um
in a distance D with Delta equals the
minimum
number of balls
of radius
Delta
um in this metric d
needed
to cover
the n
uh rich and more algebraically it's the
smallest m
such that
there are points X1 to XM
um and
BN is contained in the union of I is 1
to M of the ball of radius
are around each of the radius Delta
around each of the X I's
okay
okay so
um
the goal so this is basically a thing
called Dudley's inequality and it
reduces bounding it reduces
whether n of X is a sparsifier to
basically bounding these covering
numbers these cover numbers once again
are I have the norm ball these are the
set of points that I'm considering when
I want to understand how to sparsify so
to cover these by balls in the metric d
let me just try to give us a little bit
of an idea of why this holds
like the way that the Norms are being
basically deadly's inequality holds for
any process is satisfies the claim uh
yes yeah yeah that's a good yeah W's
inequality holds for any process that
satisfies this claim above
um the main point is that the square
root log is like the inverse function of
this x to the minus uh Kappa squared
that's where it comes from to give it a
little bit of an idea of
where this comes from
basically here's here's where this comes
from
let's say we want to understand
for a fixed point x how to spark like
let's try to understand for a fixed
point x uh whether this is true so
um okay let's write a point x
let's take a point x in b n
right and now let's let X 0 x 1 be a
sequence of points
and let's say that x i
the distance between x and x i is in
most something like 2 to the minus I
we're going to take a sequence of points
that gets closer and closer to the point
x and we can write n of X as
basically n of x 0 Plus
um
this way
yeah what's up
then it seems like this Max quantity
could could be arbitrary large but you
still satisfy the tailband in the claim
you know it's an expectation
I'm not sure I got that so if I mean so
until the equals end in expectation
right
yeah yeah that's critical yeah um that's
that's because of how the sampling
weights are defined right now all these
everything is correct in expectation and
the goal is just about the tails in all
cases
so get an idea of where this holds I'm
not going to say too much about it but
the basic idea behind the proof is to
write
n of X as the following basically
telescoping series
so now if you wanted to bound this and
expectation it suffices to bound each of
these terms separately
right
um
now for each of these terms here notice
that well basically what's going to
happen is x0 is going to come from a
discrete set that is represented by this
covering number x0 is going to be like a
point that is
going to be a point that's one the
center of one of these balls X1 is two
so each of these is going to be like a
finite number of objects that we need to
bound and because we have this tail then
you'll bound each of these by turn off
bound and then it telescopes up
basically and the integral is just going
over different levels of scale that's
basically where that's coming from
x to the minus Square yes that's right
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's to like yeah
it's basically if you like what turn off
says on each of these separate things
and then you integrate like kind of your
summing over each of the terms
uh sorry the claim not turn off my phone
yeah it's the claim
yeah it's because of the claim and the
interest
okay so for the remainder of the talk
I'm going to describe how to pick the
probabilities pi and how to bound the
covering numbers
so to start let me Define what the
probabilities PIR
ing pis
so
uh here's how the pis will be defined
I'm going to define the following
measure mu on RN so mu here is
proportional to e to the minus n of X
this is a log concave Distribution on RN
and we're going to Define pi
to be the expectation of x from mu of n
i of X and then times rho rho is going
to be some over sampling parameter and
in the end we're going to pick rho tubia
basically it's going to be logged to the
1.5
because maybe 3.5 uh it's gonna be
something like this
you don't need to worry too much about
what it is now we're going to just
decide it at the end
okay
I want to compare this a little bit to
how sparsification for other settings
works just to give an idea
um
um just as a point of comparison to L2
in L2 what ends up happening is you
actually pick pi to be the following so
L2 is remember that F5 of X is a i dot x
squared here Pi is going to be a I
transpose M inverse a i
uh and then also times this row where
here m is the the total Matrix sum over
I
another way to yeah so that's just a
point of comparison
um I guess the apis aren't necessarily
less than one but you just take the max
of the minimum of this in one yeah yeah
let's not worry too much about these
points so as James says pis might be
greater than one but let's not worry too
much about that let's just say that like
less than one it makes it's a little
easier
so now
um
now given these pis
let me State the main covering number
bound
Ary level
so the covering number of BN by D
with Delta is going to be at most
X
of
gonna be a log to the 1.5
of M
um
and then times 1 over rho times one over
Delta squared
now let me try to use that to conclude
the proof first before
showing it basically
concluding let me call this like Lemma
one or something
to conclude
from level one
I'm just going to apply Dudley
and if you apply Dudley then what do you
get well you get that the error there
I'm gonna call that the uh let me just
write it like expected value of Max Over
N X and most one
n of x minus and tilde of x
is the utmost integral
square root log of that so square root
of log to the 1.5 M over rho times one
over Delta squared because
1 over Delta times
square root log to the 1.5 M over rho
um so you might be a little worried here
now because this integral does not
converge for zero Delta being zero zero
and infinity
um but it's in but it's a a standard
thing that happens in these Dudley
integrals that
really what you what you're supposed to
do is in this integral you break it into
a few parts you break it
uh how do I want to write this
um basically what happens is
the integral breaks into a few parts
um
there's the part where Delta is less
than one over poly M there's the part
where it's greater than poly m
and uh those parts in generally they
they're negligible they contribute a
small amount and the only parts that are
critical are between these two so then
you get it's in most
log M
Times log to the 1.5 M over rho so for
the choice as we said rho is log to the
3.5 M over Epsilon squared then this is
nmost O of Epsilon and that completes
the proof
okay
so yeah for the rest of the talk I guess
the main goal will be to show this uh
covering number bound
uh were there any questions before I go
into that last part of the talk
yeah
it's like those small those parts that
you throw out of the integral you have
better coloring numbers that's correct
yeah
um okay good uh yeah so uh I guess the
question was in the parts I throw from
the integral do I have better covering
numbers and the answer is yes the reason
mainly is because it's okay so um I
guess I wrote this right you can also
show the much easier covering number
bound BN D Epsilon is the most something
like o of 1 over Delta to the power n
um this is just or only maybe nrm or
something like I think n maybe m
um and the reason is because you can
kind of just look at each function in
the sum and just discretize it by Delta
over M or something like that
and this is much better than this bound
if Delta is one over poly M so then if
you plug this in to deal with the small
parts then
you're done and for the large Parts
basically the cover number is zero so
that's why they go away
but then
the ball holder folder for which I
just F1 plus one how big is its radius
measured according to D or yeah um good
that's a good question how large is
radius measure to D it's basically going
to be at most one yeah um but I guess
you're gonna have to so that means that
when that is more than one because every
number becomes one and it's one and then
and then yeah exactly yeah but but to
see that I'm gonna have you kind of have
to go through most of this proof or like
some amount of that proof so
um oh it's not something that just comes
from the definitions no it comes with
the definition of the pi but like to see
why the cover number becomes one you
actually have to kind of walk through
the proof of this already so unless
James has it easier no I'm just saying
that the the down on the covering number
like that's
they're generally speaking they'll fall
so when you're done with the symbol when
you wrote down this one yeah because
when you
because you had to you kind of wrote it
like it's a real thing but I would I
don't think so we need to know this
stuff
uh oh okay okay you might be right yeah
but I'm not gonna go too much into that
obviously
um
okay let me try to walk through this
this uh Discovery number round for the
rest of the talk
foreign
[Music]
number bound works is so let's think
about what the goal is we want to show
that we can cover
you want to show that we can cover this
BN with balls in the radius D so by
packing covering Duality it basically
suffices to understand what's the
largest number of balls that I can pack
into BN that are diameter like radius
about Delta over 2 or Delta over four in
D
BN let's say
we went to uh
we have a bunch of balls that we want to
pack inside
and let's say the radiator like Delta
over two
then if you were to scale up each of
these if these were maximal and I was to
scale up each of the balls by a factor
of a constant then I end up covering
everything this is packing cover Duality
so it's suffices to understand what's
the maximum number of balls that I can
pack inside and the basic idea behind
this proof is something called the
sudokov method where you basically
understand what is the measure of each
of these disjoint balls under some
measure
um the measure that we're going to use
is basically this log concave measure
here
and then because the total measure is
the most one that gives you a bound on
the total number of balls so let's try
to execute this proof now
um to execute this proof let me Define a
slightly different measure mu Lambda
which is going to be proportional to e
to the minus Lambda n of x
where I'm going to choose Lambda a
little later well I guess I'll just
write down what it is now um
yeah it's going to be log to the 1.5 M
and then times Delta to the minus 2
times 1 over rho radius
e to the Lambda I mean mu Lambda is
going to be proportional to here and
we're going to try to understand what is
the measure of each of these balls in
under mu Lambda okay
so complete the proof well let me uh let
me write K so K is going to be
um
I need to do one thing before this ah
okay
uh I guess before starting I need to do
one more thing which is to simplify the
distance D which did I erase the
distance D
it was here okay that's not good
um okay so uh I guess let me rewrite
what D was which is
the square root of the sum over I
of n i x minus n i y
squared over
p i
the first step is going to be to
simplify this D or to Upper bound it
and to Upper bound it um we're going to
just write its at most sum over
of n i x minus y times Nix Plus niy
over p i
this is the most sum
i n m
Max
NM
and i x minus y over p i
sum
I X Plus n i y
which is then most
square root Max
I in m
square root of NX Plus
and Y okay so now if X and Y are inside
this ball b n that I've defined then
this is just in most up to constants
square root Max
I in m
i x minus y over Pi okay
so this is going to be kind of the new
distance that I'm actually going to use
I'm not going to really deal with this
old one because it's more complicated
but inside this ball b and then I'm
considering this is the important
distance it's square root of the max of
the ratio of the Norm I between X and Y
divided by p i
okay
um
foreign
now to continue let's define the body K
to be basically the set of points around
the origin that's small with respect to
their that distance
so
um
we call this distance D Bar of X Y
K is going to be the points X such that
the max over I of n i x over Pi is in
most Delta squared so I guess that means
the square root is the most Delta
now
the proof will follow from the following
two claims the first of which I will
defer to the end and the second which is
easier
the first is that for this choice of
Lambda then mu Lambda of K is at least
one half
um but the measure of this centered set
is at least one half this will follow
from basically concentration of log
concave distributions in the kls uh
conjecture results
and the second Lemma is that
if
um
is that for any
x i
uh with
I should write x i n b n any x i in the
norm ball then
mu Lambda of
the ball in D Bar around x i of radius
Delta which is as defined exactly equals
mu Lambda of x i plus k
is at least one half e to the minus
Lambda okay
let's see the proof of this first
you can see that mu Lambda of x i plus K
this shifted ball over the original is
the following
integral uh Y in k e to the minus Lambda
n of x i plus y
divided by integral Y and K uh
y
um
why because this is the definition of mu
Lambda over there okay now by the
triangle inequality on the numerator
this is going to be at least e to the
minus Lambda n of x i which is e to the
minus Lambda and then combining this uh
combining this sequence of inequalities
with the above claim gives the result
uh at least is correct
yeah but
BN itself
um at most one it's going to be a most
one yeah the measure of being is the
most one because it's a I mean it's a
measure
oh just because yeah and Define
everything to be a measure yeah
okay
so now uh let me
let me uh just let me now finish the
proof of llama one
okay so now let's say that X1
XM
are such that
foreign
Delta R disjoint
then clearly
um well sum of mu Lambda B D Bar x i
Delta is at most one well I guess it's
the most you know mu of
mu Lambda of RN
the most one so that means m is the most
two e to the Lambda
and for the choice of Lambda that we
made it's uh it's fine
okay
okay so I guess uh last part now will be
to understand
this uh this claim that the mass mu
Lambda of K is at least one half
foreign
so remember what K is K is
uh remember okay is K is exactly defined
as the points X where ni of X over uh
the pis is and most
um
Delta squared right okay
so
it suffices to show that the probability
of x from mu Lambda that n i x over p i
is greater than Delta squared
uh showing so that this is the most 1
over 2m and then we can Union bound over
each of the eyes okay
we'll show this and then unibound over
each of the eyes
recall what p i is p i is
expectation of x from mu which is a
slightly different distribution of n i
of x
um
so I guess times rho
this is probability X from mu Lambda
Nix greater than Delta squared rho
expectation
X in mu n i
um now let me get rid of this kind of x
from U Lambda
um so remember what mu Lambda is Mu
Lambda is like e to the minus Lambda n
of X so if we just scale X then we can
change this to X from mu and put a
Lambda on the right hand side here
um these are equal
okay
um so now by the definition of Lambda
then this is exactly a probability X in
a mu
n i x greater than log I guess c times
long to the 1.5 n
expectation X and mu
what does it say this is asking for what
the probability is that a norm that so N
I remember is a norm on RN and mu is
this log concave distribution so this is
asking what is the probability that n i
of X is greater than
poly log factors time it's times as
expectation under mu so this is
basically exactly what the recent
progress on the kls conjecture tells us
is small
um a little more formally
uh
the progress on the careless conjecture
tells us that Lipschitz functions have
sub-exponential tails uh under law
concave distributions
um Okay so
uh oh yeah let me just try to formally
State what's going on here
so I want to show that this is the most
1 over 2m we're going to require the
following
your own
um
so let Phi of n be the kls constant
on RN
then for any l-l Lipschitz function
lip shits under the euclidean norm
the uh for any l-lipshits function f and
isotropic law concave distribution mu we
have
the probability that
f of x
minus expectation f of x
greater than
L is greater than
t
is going to be at most
um e to the minus
G over L Phi of n then times the
constant C here
okay
this is due to like
it says that yeah for any l-legits
function f the probability
uh over X and A mu that f is greater
than its expectation is exponentially
decaying where PSI is the kls constant
and recently it's been shown that this
is and most root log n due to color talk
though there was a long sequence of
Works uh leave Impala I guess L down
maybe leap Impala Chen or togla Hector
steadily improve the bound
five minutes okay yeah this is
okay yeah
so
now basically I'm just going to bound
the the Lipschitz constant of the norms
and we will be done
but it's uh fortunately not a big deal
um
so I wanted to
so I wanted to bound this where mu with
some law concave distribution we can
assume that it's isotropic because you
can just do a linear transformation
doesn't affect the statement at all
um okay
so now we want to understand what is the
Lipschitz constant of a norm NX
so lip shitness
and I
n i of x minus y of x minus
ni of Y
is the most ni of x minus y
so it suffice to show that ni is lib
shoots it suffice to check that n i of X
is in most some L times x two dorm for
all X and RN
um so write n i of x to be
Max over y in the Dual Norm
of Y dot x and by koshy Schwartz this is
then most
X2 Norm times the max over Y in N star
of the L2 Norm of Y okay
now okay so that's so then basically
this is an upper boundary constant
now we want to compare this to the
expectation to conclude the proof
now notice that the expectation of x
from mu
of n i of x
is at least
expectation x to the MU of Y star dot X
absolute value we're here y star is the
ARG Max
Y and N star of Y2 Norm
okay
um and for law concave distributions all
the moments are the same up to constants
so okay
a square here
one half and then this is
X and mu y star transpose of x x
transpose y to the one-half because this
is isotropic this exactly equals two
Norm okay so that means that uh the lip
shit's constant is at most the
expectation and that completes it on
there
from
it
exclamation
um
you shouldn't think of that way you
should think that I've turned I've
transformed the norm ni into like a new
Norm
does that make sense like
um so if you want to prove this for
every Norm
maybe maybe think of it this way like
instead
think of it as like n i of ax greater
than C log to the 1.5 M expectation ni
of ax
where a is like the covariance Matrix of
mu
and then the ni I wrote over there is
actually n i of a
which is a norm on RN still
and yeah going up on the ni with the
operator normal effect of my customer or
IC so like the and I wrote over there's
actually ni of a of X like it's it's
like it's a composed thing
um and I guess okay sorry there's one
thing that I kind of forgot to mention
the whole time which is I never actually
bounded the total size of the sparsifier
but that's not too difficult
um
so I'll be done right after this
foreign
to bound to Total size
because I'm sampling with probability P
the total size is the most
the sum of the pis
and the sum of the pis
is
the expectation of the sum of N i of x
where X is from U
which is the expectation of n of X where
X is from U and mu is proportional to e
to the minus n of X and it's a nice
calculation that the expectation of x
from U where mu is this proportional to
this is actually exactly equal to n
um
and so API is rho times this my phone
row row row row N and because we chose
rho to be o tilde of one over Delta one
over Epsilon squared
that concludes proof
so I think yeah that's all I had and
thank you
questions for young
foreign
[Music]
so you can in principle implement it in
polynomial Time by example by like
sampling from the law concave
distribution uh in fact if you care you
can also get in like what people call
input scarcity which means that the
runtime is M plus polynomial in n and
where m means like M accesses to minors
yeah
can you comment a bit about uh what you
do it for square
oh
the sums of squares and norms I'm good
uh is
it like is there some kind of recovery
effective resistance oh good that's a
good question so for sums of squares of
norms
um basically the the probabilities Pi
are exactly what you expect you instead
of mu is e to the minus n of x squared
and then the piser expectation of n i of
X is squared and if you write that down
that's exactly the same as effective
resistances however it's not we don't
know how to show that if you do that
then the size will be all the way down
to like that that
um that like
maybe you can get size n over Epsilon
squared with that yeah we don't know how
to show that we only know to show what
this additional smoothness assumption
which a i dot x squared does satisfy but
positive like higher dimensional numbers
do you want to mention that that open
question
yeah okay I guess I ran out of time but
that would be a good open question
um
so
which is so let's say we have n of x
squared is sum over i and m of n i of x
squared where we have no smoothness
assumption on the ni at all these are
just arbitrary Norms then what is the
best smart City
in general if you replace these with
keys we can show a bound of O tilde n to
the 2 minus one over P times f plus
minus two so it's like n to the three
halves for p equals two but we don't
know whether anything better is
achievable
for p larger uh for p larger than two I
guess you got yeah you can also we also
don't know the right bound yeah okay uh
it's not going to be linear yeah repeat
larger than two you can never get on
linear size in general even when they're
all One X so that's why I didn't talk
about it too much
anyway I will be happy to discuss
afterwards
no more questions
[Applause]
we will see you tomorrow for the final
day